[Musique]
mardi le président américain qui est à
mi-chemette-sur-moda fera le point sur
l'état de l'Union devant un congrès
divisé avec une chambre de représentants
contrôlée par les républicains Joe Biden
veille exposer ses priorités mais a-t-il
la marge de manœuvre pour les mener à
terme on va voir ce qu'on pense ma
collègue gazelle notre bureau de
Washington bonjour
Daniel à quoi est-ce qu'on doit
s'attendre de ce de cet État de l'Union
mardi bah écoutez on a eu un avant-goût
vendredi Joe Biden a donné une
conférence de presse en disant que
l'économie va très bien il a sorti les
chiffres du mois de janvier en disant
qu'il y a eu une création de plus de 500
000 emplois juste pour le mois de
janvier que le taux de chômage est à son
plus bas depuis 1969 c'est-à-dire 3,4%
que l'inflation est en baisse également
donc on s'attend à qui soit vraiment
positif optimiste si vos redonner
confiance aux Américains il va également
certainement parler de ces victoires
législatives observer sa loi sur la
réduction de l'inflation sur
l'environnement ou encore vous savez le
chips and Sciences Act qui veut que les
puces électroniques soient produisent
produite aux États-Unis au lieu d'aller
importer cela de la Chine donc ça va
être assez positif il va parler vraiment
de ces victoires législatives de ces
gains et donc il veut donner vraiment un
message aux Américains en disant
qu’écoutait avec moi tout va bien
également pour les élections de mi-manda
c'est lui qui les démocrates ont quand
même remporté le Sénat ce qui est très
rare quand on a les élections
demi-mandat donc on s'attend à Joe Biden
assez positif qui va vraiment parler
beaucoup de ces victoires va aussi
probablement parler de cette capacité
qu'il a déjà inventé à partir des ponts
sur quel enjeux peut-il bâtir des ponts
cette fois pour la deuxième partie de
son mandat ben écoutez ça va être
extrêmement difficile parce
qu'évidemment avec Keven macrosphy qui
est le nouveau président de la Chambre
des Représentants ils veulent pas
vraiment que Joe Biden réussisse là ils
vont lui rendre la vie extrêmement
difficile Joe Biden va évidemment tenter
de rassembler les Américains sur la
question de l'Ukraine par exemple vous
savez de l'ordre de son dernier discours
de l’être sur l'état de l'Union il
disait que voilà c'est un débat c'est
c'est soit la tyrannie soit la
démocratie donc il va parler du fait
qu'il a réussi à rassembler le monde
occidental à rassembler l'Europe à unir
l'Europe contre la Russie qu'il a réussi
également à renforcer l'OTAN donc là
dessus il va vraiment miser sur le
retour si vous voulez des États-Unis sur
la scène internationale mais pour les
républicains évidemment ils n'ont pas à
gagner enfin que Joe Biden réussisse CV
il va tenter évidemment une loi
législation sur les armes à feu sur
l'avortement également sur la réforme de
la police vous savez qu'il va y avoir la
mer de ce jeune afro-américain qui a été
abattu par des policiers le 7 janvier
dernier sa mère et son beau-père seront
au Congrès mardi soir donc il va parler
également de la réforme policière mais
les républicains vont évidemment lui
mettre les bateaux dans les roues donc
ça va être difficile pour Joe Biden ce
deuxième semi mandat bon alors quel
grand projet peut-il droit-il réussir
devant cette opposition républicaine
ça va être extrêmement difficile à
commencer par le plafond de la dette que
les démocrates aimeraient bien relever
on parle quand même d'un montant énorme
1380 milliards de dollars donc les
républicains font la fine bouche ils ne
veulent pas relever le plafond de la
dette on a jusqu'à janvier jusqu'à juin
et si jamais les paroles levées on
parlerait d'un défaut de paiement aux
États-Unis et ça ça serait
catastrophique pour l'économie
américaine évidemment on sait également
qui a le freelome crocus là dans chez
les républicains qui vont vraiment lui
mener la vie dure chaque fois qu'il va
proposer quelque chose ils vont le
bloquer et ce freelancocus on parle de
Jim Jordan de Madrid ces gens-là par
exemple ils veulent qu'on arrête l'aide
à l'Ukraine d'être militaire à l'Ukraine
qu'elle me Croissy le président de la
Chambre des représentants a déjà dit
qu'on peut pas faire un chèque en blanc
à l'Ukraine qui va falloir surveiller
donc ça va être extrêmement difficile
pour Joe Biden lors de son mi-mandat les
républicains n'ont qu'une mince majorité
donc eux non plus ne pourra pas
accomplir grand chose mais Joe Biden va
certainement continuer à bâtir sur les
acquis sur l'infrastructure donc il fait
des conférences de presse un peu partout
il se promène un peu partout aux
États-Unis pour dire regarder ça marche
on va rebâtir nos ponts on va rebâtir
nos routes nos aqueducs donc il va
vraiment miser sur les acquis et sur ce
qu'il tente de faire également sur les
énergies renouvelables on sait que les
États-Unis ont quand même investi plus
de 500 milliards de dollars la sûr
l'environnement sur les changements
climatiques c'est du jamais vu donc
c'est là-dessus vraiment que Joe Biden
va tenter de de rassembler les
Américains puisque lors de son discours
de l'État d'union évidemment qui
regardait par population c'est un des
discours les plus écoutés il va quand
même montrer qu'il est l'homme de la
situation qu'il réussit malgré ses 80
ans malgré ses critiques qu'il a quand
même réussi son pari de relever
l'Amérique de relever l'économie
américaine et puis surtout de ramener
les États-Unis sur la scène
internationale comme un joueur
incontournable est-ce que est-ce que
l'on doit surveiller est-ce que l'on
pourrait voir dans discours certains
indications de ce qu'il entrevoit pour
son avenir politique monsieur Biden
c'est la grande question il a quand même
80 ans il va avoir 82 ans en 2024 est-ce
que les Américains sont prêts à les lire
donc les gens disent écoutez il a réussi
quand même un tour de force aux
dernières élections il avait fait face à
des dizaines de candidats démocrates il
avait quand même remporté la primaire
donc il réussit quand même à rassembler
même l'aile très très à gauche de son
parti l'aile progressiste il réussit à
rassembler les Américains autour de lui
c'est la grande question certains disent
qu'en fait c'est la personne idéale qui
va tenir tête à Donald Trump comme il
l'a fait en 2020 mais il maintient le
secret on ne sait toujours pas s'il va
se présenter ou pas donc évidemment à
suivre
mardi à Zabel League ça Washington merci
infiniment d'avoir été des nôtres je
vous en prie